各位老师同学好,我是蚂蚁蜜蒜的张续峰
今天给大家分享的课题是
机密容器的安全设计及落地实践
本次课程将分为四个部分进行讲解
首先介绍机密容器产生的背景
机密容器主要解决了什么问题
以及基于Hyper Anglia的机密容器整体架构
其实讲解机密容器的安全体系设计
主要从安全格里
全链路密谈
运行通道管控三个方面
介绍机密容器提供的安全能力
第三,讲述机密容器的信任体系设计
作为可执行环境TE技术的重要一部分
机密容器是如何实现信任内容传递的
最后,以多方数据联合计算为场景
介绍机密容器在可信数据空间领域的落地实践
首先看第一个部分
在数字经济时代,数据作为第五大生产要素
以成为驱动经济质量发展的关键要素
近年来,国家高度重视数据要素市场的培育
与发展工作
陆续出台了一系列的政策法规
比如数据20条
数据要素X,12年行动计划
明确数据处理活动的要求
为数据要素市场驻劳政策根基
推动数据安全有序流通
为救助创新指明方向
在此背景下
我国数据要素市场迎来高手发展期
2005年1月
国家数据局局长在全国公众会议上表示
2024年
全国数据交易规模超一千六百亿元
同比增长本30亿上
然而,蓬勃发展的市场背后
数据流通与融合
面临著多严峻挑战
一方面,数据具有排大性
异与复制性等特点
一旦泄漏或被滥用
价值将极具萎缩
会给企业带来重大损失
另一方面
大数据相关法规的实施
使企业和机构
在数据共享与使用过程中
面临更苛刻的合规要求
违规风险显著叛生
此外,明文数据的流通
无法实现有效的管控
数据泄漏的成本和频率
居高不下
一旦发生数据泄漏
不仅会给企业带来直接的经济损失
还会损害用户的信任
那么为了破解数据要受流通难的问题
一般是采用密台计算的解决方案
所谓密台计算
是指的数据在计算过程中
始终属于加密状态
密台计算通过综合利用密码学
可信硬件和系统安全等相关技术
确保数据在跨阻底流通的
传输存储计算
全量流通始终保持密台
密台计算代表性的技术
包括精明计算
MPC多方安全计算
同台加密等技术
从性能方面考虑
精明计算是目前
作为现实的一种密台计算技术
精明计算通过基于硬件
提议保护使用中的数据
它也硬件隔离技术
数据加密技术
远程证明机制作为一图
实现数据的可用不可见
可算不可实
精明计算支持海量数据
和大规模和大模型训练推理
并将成本控制在
明文流通的2-10倍之间
和规模方面具备优势
能够满足大规模数据融合场景中
安全的诉求
让数据可信流通
实现从能用到好用易用的跨越
有效解决数据明文流通
风险不收敛的严峻产严挑战
从精明计算历史来看
在数据中心场景
并且出现了不同的形态
最早期是英特尔SGS
它是一种进程机T1技术
可以在CPU隔离的可承应环境内
执行进程的代码
因而它的优点是T2B很小
安全性高
但是它的缺点也很明显
一个是需要对应用进行改造
缺分成可信部分和不可信部分
可信部分运行在T1内部
不可信部分运行在R1议册
T1和R1需要通过依靠
侮靠机制进行通信
这个上向文切换的成本比较高
导致SGS程序的运行能比较差
所以后面是没有赏伤
为了解决监控性导致的开发成本高的问题
推出了精明训绩的解放
比较有代表性的是英特尔TDS
AMDSEV SMP
AMDSEV HIFER ANGLE
由于精明训绩内运行的是原生的Lanning的操作系统
所以应用程序无意改造
就可以运行在精明训绩内部
提供了最好的兼容性
而且可信的设备
比如带新的GPU设备
可以折通到精明训绩内部
非常适合高性能计算的场景
但是精明训绩也有它自身的缺点
一个是训绩内部运行的是整个Lanning的操作系统
导致它的TCB比较大
安全风险高
另外就是精明训绩部署管理比较困难
需要依赖20层提供的能力
后来TDSU继续眼镜
把精明训绩和CataCondins的
原生继续相接合
出现了精明容计新的形态
带来的优势是显而易见的
一个是可以附用现有的原生技术设施
有利精明训绩的大规模部署管理
另外一个优点是更小的TCB
可以基于CataCondins的对训绩操作系统
进行深度拆建
直暴流必须的逐渐
大大减小了安全场口
前面也提到精明容计是基于Cata的
那么怎么来看一下Cata相关的安全设计
最初Cata是为原生多组互强格雷场景设计的
传统的软系容器
虽然基于Lim Space和Seguru的设计
具有一定的格雷能力
但是由于底层还是共享零能内核
一旦容器讨议后
就会影响其他的组互
Cata的出现正为了解决这个问题
CataCondins基于QM硬件训续化的技术
把轻量化的训绩
构建为一种容器运行形态
所以Cata最初的目标是
防止容器的逃逸
保护云技术设施免受攻击
它的安全模型是不信任
容器内运行的World
是安全容器的一种实现形态
精明容器也是基于CataCondins的
容器运行时
除了QM训续化技术外
还通过集成T1硬件格雷
全量路加密远程证明等
影视保护方案
对使用中的数据进行保护
所以它的安全模型和
安全容器完全反过来
云技术设施或数据不再可信
需要保护的是容器内
数据的精明性和完整性
所以安全容器和精明容器
虽然有一些共性
但由于它们应用场景的差异
在安全方面的设计完全不同
下面重点介绍
基于HyperAngle-5精明容器相关的设计
先看一下它的主要特点
首先来说
相比于其他基于CPU硬件的T1设计
HyperAngle-5的目标
是让所有CPU都具备T1的能力
当前已经支持了国内外主流的CPU平台
比如Intel、AMD、AM等
所以普会通用是HyperAngle-5的一大优势
其次HyperAngle-5由于
不是利用CPU自身的提议
底层的性能设计
基于通用的TBM硬件
而TBM证书是通过
国家权威的CPU经济签发
因而可以说
HyperAngle-5的性能根与CPU厂商结合
性能根拖拐在国家的权威
自主可控是HyperAngle-5的一大亮点
另外HyperAngle-5最核心的
Hyper外的组建
是基于安全变成语言RAS开发
而且通过了权威机构的行动化认证
安全可证是HyperAngle-5的基石
最后HyperAngle-5自身的
核应带马银开源
而且兼容Occlum,Coco,Linux等开源生态
应用无需特殊改造
即可升级为机密应用
简单应用是HyperAngle-5一直
秉承的理念
下面讲一下机密容器的
安全体系设计
也就是机密性的保护机制
从安全隔离上来说
HyperAngle-5启动后
会作为最高特缘软件
直接运行在硬件之上
后摄物还是会被降权
所以后摄物还是所有特缘操作
都会被HyperAngle-5安全审计
如果不符合安全层面的设计
操作会被阻断
HyperAngle-5实现了
三个层面的隔离
首先HyperAngle-5管理
所有的安全内存
这些安全内存
会分辨给机密容器
HyperAngle-5通过内存业表机制
控制软件对安全内存的防卫
实现RE和TE之间
以及机密容器之间的内存隔离
其实HyperAngle-5在
进行上下文切换的时候
会清理CPU技能器
可以保证RE看不到TE的状态数据
机密容器A
也看不到机密容器B的状态数据
实现CPU状态的隔离
还有就是可信的设备
可以通过VFRO的机制
直通到机密容器
比如GPU设备
为了防止RE世界
修叹到设备内存的数据
我们还需要对设备进行隔离
设备隔离的实现
是通过HyperAngle-5
控制泡打RO
和管理ROMU
地址翻译界表
保护设备的控制面和数据面
安全隔离仅仅能在权限层面
限制特选软件和管理员
它不能完全解决数据的机密性
还需要实现全链路的密台
而这里的密台计算
并不是指对密台数据直接进行计算
而是指对于RE来说
看到的都是密台数据
数据加密后流入机密容器
只在硬件隔离的被认证的
提议环境进行解密计算
另外通过CPU内置的内存加密引擎
可以对内存中的数据
进行自动加密
以抵于潜在的物理攻击
比如库德布特内存攻击
对于机密容器来说
容器镜像在盖车OS里面拉取
容器镜像也是被保护的对象
为了防止RE独取这些数据
我们需要对落盘的容器镜像
以及运营时临时落盘数据进行加密
这里面的挑战是机密容器重启后
如果附用之前的容器镜像数据
具体的解决方案这里就不展开
同样的机密容器
也有持有化落盘数据的需求
比如密台数据部的场景
针对这些数据也需要使能
赤盘透明加密的能力
T1环境中传输的数据
也是被保护的重点对象
一部分是CPU和可信设备之前
总线传输的数据
或者是可信设备与可信设备
之间也总线传输的数据
为了防止对总线的秀碳
窃取数据
需要对总线上传输的数据
另外一部分也是
通过网络传输的数据
可以把医药容器发送的网络数据包
透明截至到加密网关
保证流出T1环境的网络数据
是自动加密的
目标端T1环境
收到网络数据包后
进行自动解密并转发到医药容器
不同于传统的原生容器
我们需要保护机密容器数据隐私
因而常规的运营通道
需要进行限制和管控
比如锅盖上ERGC
刀扣ERGC等通道
而另外一个方面
为了保证线上业务的可运性
我们不能把运营通道一刀切完全堵死
所以安全管控机制上
需要对安全和运营之间进行权衡
可以从以下几个方面
对运营通道进行重心防御
第一个是API程的防护
T1和RE之间最重要的交互通道
就是CATASIM和CATASIM之间的RPC通路
锅盖上ERGC之类的运营通道
就是走的这种方式
我们可以通过Initial Data Policy的方式
限制该通道的运营之间的操作
该方案主要是利用了OPA Policy的能力
这种策略配置的方式偏静态
第二种是系统层面的防护
可以通过可运运营服务
动态下发安全策略
该策略可以基于EVPF实现
EVPF是一种可以动态注入字节码
到任何的技术
支持大量的护火点
可以对高威操作经审计或者阻断
第三点就是运营输出加密
秉承着T1流出的数据
全程密带的原则
我们可以对运营通道
执行命令的IDL输出
进行自动加密
只有被特殊授权的运营人员
才可以看到运营数据
最后一点就是运营操作的审计存证
T1内所有运营操作
都透明的都是可以被审计的
而且审计纪录不可篡改
接下来介绍
精密容器的信任体系设计
也就是完整性保护机制
T1最重要的一个技术点
就是远程证明机制
如果证明程序执行的环境是可信的
首先说一下
据Hyper Angle的精密容器
启动信任内建立的过程
TPM作为整个系统的信任根
继续上年后
会把启动的组件
包括固件
UEF,Bootload,Kner
Ninth Run Models
可能可能满满
这些组件的度量值
扩展到TPM PTR精神器
Ninth Run Models加在Drawer Module
Drawer Module会加在Hyper Angle
并把启动度量值
扩展到TPM PTR精神器
Hyper Angle启动后
会把后手OS降级为非特选模式
Hyper Angle作为精密容器的信任根
建立精密容器的启动信任内
包括启动度量,TTCM
改成Kner
可能可满满
这些
改成OS系统
入单发射分区
为内核的DM2T机子
完成性保护
该驯动分区的入单发射
配置在Kner
可能可满满
从而把精密容器的启动信任量
扩展到系统服务
保证精密容器
系统车的启动组件
都是符合预期的
通过增强
概设内核中的IME模块
应用容器在被
驯动服务组件
拉起过程中
执行二进日的度量启动
和安全启动
安全救援失败的容器
会被阻担运行
从而把启动信任内
传递到应用式
保障精密容器
启动链条上的任何组件
都是经过完整性认证的
经过了精密容器的
可信启动过程
要容器就可以发起
远程证明
以获取应用的可信身份
要容器必要用
Alt-TazenAgent提供的借口
Alt-TazenAgent
调用设备驱动
获取远程证明报告
设备驱动
会通过HyperCore借口
调用HyperAngle
获取最终的报告
Alt-TazenAgent
把报告发送给远程证明服务
远程证明服务
对报告的完美性
进行交易
并比对极限
远程证明后
给应用办法可信身份
同时把自信的报告
返回给Alt-TazenAgent
Alt-TazenAgent
教验远程证明服务的报告
进行双向远程证明
远程证明后
返回可信身份
给要容器
而右边这幅图
是远程证明报告的
新令代码关系
从下到上
除TPMM硬件中的AK迷恙
担保了TPMM擴大中的
PCR值的完整性
其中PCR0-9
担保平台完整性
PCR12
担保HyperAngle的完整性
TPMMPCR13
担保HyperAngleAK的完整性
HyperAngleAK
是从TPMM硬件排身
它用来担保
CVM Quota的完整性
CVM Quota中
MRTD担保TTCM
固件的完整性
RTMR0和1
担保概冊OS的完整性
RTMR2担保容器
累计度量值的完整性
容器累计度量值
担保容器二金字
度量事件的完整性
这样就形成一个
完备的新令代码关系
然后
医药容器会到可信身份后
就可以基于可信身份
从密药管理服务
尝试会有密药
密药管理服务
验证完应用的身份
基于体验配置好的
密药数源策略
进行健全
健全成功后
返回加密后的密药数据
最后讲一下机密容器
在多方数据联合计算场景
方便的时间
对于一个典型的数据流传场景
数据提供方将自由数据
上传到数据中心
由数据加工应用进行处理
主要设计到设立角色
一个是TES
也就是数据提供方
自由数据处理
被第三方应用处理
担心数据处理的安全
第二个是可信应用
也就是第三方数据处理服务
需要保障数据安全
运行在机密容器中
需要自证清买
第三个是密药管理服务
它管理数据密药
和相应的密药数据策略
同样运行在机密容器中
需要自证清买
第四个是远程证明服务
它作为整个数据中心的
心灵根存在
它自身的心灵根
是在TBM硬件
远程证明服务
验证应用的远程证明报告
同样运行在机密容器中
需要自证清买
数据流转的主要流程留下
可信应用注册应用机线
到远程证明服务
可信应用不受启动后
通过远程证明
获取可信身份
通过可信身份
在密药管理服务
创建KK密药
数据提供方TESA
配置KK密药授权策略
然后TESA从远程证明服务
获取报告
TESA通过全域机构
或者第三方中立机构
验证远程证明报告的
验证远程证明服务的报告
验证成功后
就证明了数据中心
远程证明服务的可信性
后面就可以信任远程证明服务
颁发的可信身份
或者叫认证偷轨
然后TESA从密药管理服务
获取KK工药
KK工药的完成性
有密药管理服务的偷轨弹幕
TESA教验密药管理服务的偷轨
和KK工药的完成性
然后使用KK工药
加密数据加密密药
DK
DK加密数据
密文数据
组成数字新分后
发送给可信应用
可信应用为了解密数据
需要获取KK私药
KK私药通过应用可信身份
从密药管理服务获取
可信应用获取到KK私药后
对DK进行解密
DK对数据进行解密
然后对数据进行处理
整个过程
对硬件可信跟的远程证明机制
实现了对可信应用授权
与密药安全流转
数据提供方TESA
根据公开的信息
发布密药验证策略
可以安全地把加密数据
只传出给授权的TESA应用
最后
密药的名为
只出现在TESA内部
而且只能被特定的
可信应用获取
管理员和其他恶意程序
不能通过任何手段
获取到密药的名为
从而保证的数据密药
在生存 存储 传输 使用
各环境的安全
接着保证数据适用权的可信流转
下面看一个更真实的
可信数据空间
多方数据联合计算的场景
从下面图可以看到
里面包含了多个数据提供方
统一的数据加工方
和潜在的多个数据消费方
密调数据接入
由数据提供方
在接入端对原始数据进行加密
加密或者数据
以密文的形态
流入加工平台
加解密密药
是由密药管理服务
掌握的一对公司药
接入端从密药管理服务
获取加密工药
对数据进加密封装后
流入数据加工方平台
密调数据封装后
归在数据加工方平台
分类后进行密调的存储
然后对密调数据进行治理
通过自动化的清洗
去从 检验 比对
合成 脱米等流程
确保数据的准确性
完成性 一致性 还有实际性
密调数据研发
对治理或者数据
通过找数 设数 严数
完成代码逻辑见证
该阶段输出数据计算逻辑
密调数据服务环节
是数据加工方
使用研发态产生的计算逻辑
或者模型进行密调计算
生成密调计算的结果
并发布为数据产品
对外提供服务
密调数据交互阶段
在获得数据提供方
授权的前提下
被授权捣出的数据
可以以密纹形态留足平台
且留足的密纹数据
只能被以获取授权的数据消费方
获得
而以上数据加工每个环节
都涉及到
基于机密容器 提议相关技术
包括生品验证 授权健全
环境度量 服务度量
密调计算 可信審计等
只有验证和授权通过后
才能进行相关的数据解密
数据计算 数据流出等操作
可信数据空间
基于权链路密带保障
实现原始数据不可见
计算过程密带化
操作全程可審计等多重防护
可防范内部人员恶意操作的风险
有效破解高价值高敏感
数据流通难论
另外 基于可信应用生费
和密带交道技术
购物件数据使用权跨越管控能力
打破数据持有防
与运用方的信任秘累
确保数据的流通
利用符合停工方的预期
即使运用等内部人员
也无法滥用数据
利用密带计算
购物件密耀管控的
虚拟数据空间边界
形成具有明确级别
安全保障的密耀管控域
替代原有的运用管控域
物理管控域边界
基于密耀管控域
可以对多方数据融合的价值
进行验证
有效促进多方主体
协同推进数据要素
全流通的安全流通
形成良性循环的数据要素
市场生态
本次课程主要介绍的内容
就是这些
如果想对机密容器
经营不了解的同学
可以参考下面的拓展资料
包括卡达·康廷的社区
康贝丹萨·康廷的社区
和星达社区
里面有很多关于机密容器
实现的详细微浪资料
和代码细节
感谢大家的联听